they've not been seen in the uk since
june but listen to the crowd when megan
and harry turned up
they chose privacy in california but in
manchester it was spotlights and center
stage for the sussexes
good evening everyone
it is
very nice to be back in the uk
megan knows when she speaks people
listen
you are the future
but i would like to add to that
that you are also
the present
you are the ones driving the positive
and necessary change needed across the
globe now in this very moment
and for that
i'm so grateful to be in your company
today
it was the kind of speech no other royal
would make and this her home crowd a
cause megan championed long before she
met harry little surprised the audience
here loved it
super model halima aiden even took a
sussex selfie
i know myself i was so pumped and
excited to see her speak and i think it
was the perfect kickoff to one young
world these are young people yes they're
leaders they're doing incredible
inspiring things but they needed that
like little boost of energy to really
like get started
this was megan's first public speech
here since leaving the uk and her royal
role and far less controversial than
recent interviews exposing rifts with
the royal family
this was not your typical royal visit
there was no red carpet no photo moments
just backdoor arrivals and private
security but this is the sussexes making
an appearance their way
their mini tour does not it seem include
any time with the royal family but they
know the connection still gives them a
platform and for now the world will be
watching their every move laura bundock
sky news manchester